quelques temps je disais je vais faire
une faq on va se la faire à new york
voilà un rendez-vous que j'aime bien
avec vous c'est la fameuse faq pouvoir
se retrouver pour discuter ensemble
parler vous répondra à toutes vos
questions
et aujourd'hui on fait dans un lieu un
petit peu exceptionnel carrément
exceptionnelle j'en avais déjà parlé il
ya qu'elle se sent nous voilà
aujourd'hui à new york city regardez-moi
ça la voilà il fait super beau et fait
très chaud ouah je peux pas trop ouvrir
je suis un petit peu embêté bon bah
c'est pas un il ya beaucoup de bruit
voyez new york city je crois qu'au fond
on doit avoir un espace de central park
sur 21e étage ici d'un hôtel dans le
centre de new york
c'est franchement hypra coup je me mets
en face vous entendrez un petit peu
mieux comme ça je suis venu ici passer
deux jours deux jours et demi avec
microsoft pour parler de plein de doutes
et je vous en parle demain donc
revenez demain sur la chaîne vous saurez
tout et puis là j'ai une piaule qui
percute j'aime bien partager ces petits
moments avec vous à vous montre un petit
peu les piaules d'hôtel regardez-moi ça
c'est hyper canon avec la vue comme ça
c'est hyper sweety joli petit plus hyper
cool salut c'est moi en face
regardez ça regardez comme elle coule
c'est vraiment hyper sympa alors moi ce
que j'adore dans les hôtels sont abordés
des noirs pas si c'est votre cas mais
moi j'adore ça comme ça je peux mais
ailleurs à se mettre dedans et hop voilà
en face on a et on est juste là en face
la ici vous avez laissé bon sens de la
vie faire donc un truc hyper cool on va
parler justement des surfaces demain et
regardez ce que microsoft m'a gentiment
offert son aide que welcome pack en fait
pourtant souhaiter la bienvenue on vous
fait des petits cadeaux et c'est très
mignon très sympa hein
voilà c'est très gentil surtout après
des heures et des heures de vol une
arrivée un petit peu compliqué à
l'immigration ça prend un temps de
dingue mais bon voilà
me voilà il est regardé petit peu corp
de sheila des cornichons jeu
j'ai brisé dans les combien de bonnes
idées si mac microsoft ça c'est hypra
coup et puis un adaptateur
voilà pour se brancher bon on se fait
une petite faq je vous dis restez
connectés parce que demain on va parler
justement de microsoft y avoir vachement
cool à raconter mais par contre petit
leur est venue faire la faq
alors on y va
[Musique]
non
bonjour cas smartphone faudrait prendre
entre le p 30 pro et le note 10 plus
alors ça dépend ce qu'on voulait faire
notre 10 plus c'est vraiment avec le
stylet usage style et si c'est pour la
photo les deux sont vraiment très très
bon vraiment très excellent voilà pour
moi la question à se poser c'est le
style est d'avis tu n'as pas besoin du
style et va sur le pétrole pro bon alors
quoi c'est souvent une question de prix
le p 33 blessés il sera un peu moins
cher et franchement il est vraiment très
très bien gars tu les roches où tu te
plantes ou dessus bafouille pour un
bêtisier éventuel oui je sais je sais
écoute moi en fait je garde tout tout
est gardée j'ai tous mes rêves tous les
côtés alors je bafouille où je garde pas
trop je pourrais faire un montage mais
en fait une vidéo où on me raid
entièrement bafouillé je serai prêt ce
désastre et ibrahim jeilan tout cas
merci pour la question tony que faut-il
choisir entre eux juan plus est chez
ovide
ça dépend vraiment des goûts personnels
ça dépend ce que vous voulez ça dépend
quel modèle dans la gamme
voilà ça c'est vraiment une question pas
compliqué répond parce que j'ai pas de
modèle face à face j'ai vraiment deux
marques face à face les deux sont bien
compliqué de répondre tu déjà testé le
blackberry ou pro non seb
comment rejoindre la team groupe facile
bouton rejoindre juste en dessous de la
vidéo je sais jamais si c'est là aussi
c'est la bouton rejoindre vous cliquez
et puis ensuite vous choisissez ce qui
vous intéresse le petit forfait et puis
voilà bienvenue dans les tim grubb
penses tu que one + va être un grand
concurrent pour un peu les samsung dans
un futur proche je pense que c'est déjà
le cas en fait parce que de toute façon
il faut raisonner en termes de ventes et
one + existe propose des modèles
intéressants sur nos concurrents
ils sont encore pas au niveau en terme
de ventes de samsung et d'apple en tout
cas c'est un vrai concurrent sérieux qui
je pense va continuer à développer dans
les années à venir
rémy note 7 ou iphone 6h30 notre set
entre le s10 et le note 10 lequel le
meilleur photo et qualité prix toujours
la même réponse par rapport au style
l'es10 et très bien le no 10 est très
bien également
on a des petites évolutions 3 is hell no
10 mais franchement c'est pas énorme
surtout c'est la question du style et
s'il te faut pas à deux styles et ne va
pas du tout sur le note dit si tu veux
c'est aider sur le note 10 mai les deux
ans photos sont vraiment excellents
bonjour un lien ne penses tu que le web
et 30 pro est toujours meilleur est
toujours le meilleur photophone de
l'année 2019
il est sorti au qu'il comprend alors est
ce que c'est le meilleur photophone de
l'année 2019
c'est un des meilleurs c'est
indéniablement un des meilleurs huawei a
fait un excellent boulot gros travail en
r&d derrière la qualité est bien le truc
est vraiment bien moi je chante quoi
c'est pour l'instant un des meilleur
photophone pas forcément de l'année 2019
parce que là n'est pas terminé il ya le
google pixels 4 qui arrive bientôt
je demande un peu à voir en tout cas oui
c'est un excellent photophone as-tu
pensé à une rubrique concernant des
applis pratique surprenante nul
gd je me suis posé la question fait de
parler d'applications mais non parce
qu'en fait il y aurait tellement de
choses à dire ça demanderait aussi
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de sujets du
coup pour l'instant j'ai mis un peu
l'idée de côté d'ailleurs si ça vous
intéresse dites le moi en bas en
commentaire tu vas voir le nouveau pour
8 très bientôt
raynaud de on en parle très très bientôt
que devient la chaîne monsieur gros
anglaise le fouet alors ça c'est une en
début d'année j'ai voulu lancer la
chaîne monsieur version us pour
effectivement lanciers autre chose je
trouvais ça cool mais je me suis
retrouvé confronté un très gros problème
de temps très rapidement du coup pour
l'instant la chaîne monsieur bré
anglaise les deux côtés est la moins de
1000 abonnés et j'avais un vrai problème
je faisais x 1,50 ans de travail c'était
pas parfait il y avait plein de choses à
revoir peut-être l'année prochaine on
verra en fonction de l'évolution comment
je peux faire ce que c'est un peu
compliqué apple ou samsung
ça dépend les deux sont vraiment
excellentes est ce une bonne affaire
d'acheter un iphone 7 aujourd'hui c'est
toujours une question de budget ça
marche bien mais je pense qu'au prix
d'un iphone 7 on peut avoir aujourd'hui
beaucoup mieux mais après une fois de
plus vous aurez pas ios moment la
question se pose là dessus il lui faut
un million d'abonnés pour faire une
rencontre avec sa communauté à croire
que nous ne sommes pas grand chose n'est
pas si elle pourrait avoir mon nom dans
la dernière es facture suis désolé lucas
excusez moi si je me suis mal exprimé ou
mal dit les choses ont pas forcément
contacter les abonnés jeudi pas pourquoi
pas au million en fait c'est que je veux
marquer le coup avec un gros événement
alors je sais je m'étais posé la
question même de faire un événement
cette fin d'année mais au final j'ai mis
un petit peu l'idée de côté pour
l'instant parce que faire une belle
rencontre abonné je voudrais faire un
truc vraiment cool qu'on puisse
valoriser passer des moments vraiment
vraiment sympa ça demande tous à une
grosse organisation et du coup je suis
bayrou il le fera on fera un tube
vraiment soit tous ensemble et du coup
j'ai dit bah pourquoi pas millions
d'abonnés mais peut-être avant je ne
sais pas mais en tout cas non c'est pas
du tout le fait de dire que c'est pourri
par ma communauté c'est pas du tout ça
au contraire à chaque fois que j'en
croise plein d'entre vous je suis il
faut près content de pouvoir échanger
discuter donc c'est toujours un beau
moment de partage donc croyez vraiment
pas ça qui est vraiment
tous vous rencontrer il faut juste
organiser ça pour soi vraiment cool est
vraiment faire un bel événement je suis
curieux de savoir c'est quoi l'histoire
du portail qui se trouve juste derrière
dans l'ex duo oui le mac que j'avais
complètement éclaté moi je ne fais une
vidéo sur apple jamais été embêté parce
que le service après vente d'apple
n'avait pas joué le jeu m'avait jamais
rappelé alors qu'ils avaient été engagés
à le faire du coup j'étais l'énergie
j'ai pris une bonne gifle éclaté voilà
qui souvenir je voulais savoir où se
trouve le studio que l'as montferrand
quand je suis de là-bas secret secret
est-ce que honor ne pourra plus utiliser
le playsport oui non alors ça reste très
flou tout ça pour l'instant tous les
modèles qui ont la certification google
ils vont pouvoir continuer à l'utiliser
on se pose la question pour les modèles
à l'avenir mais je suis persuadé qu'une
solution va être trouvée solution
politique entre la chine et les usa et
puis google forcément huawei et au nord
seront impactés par tout ça j'hésite
entre le au nord 20 le galaxy à 70 et le
minefe tn moi comme ça je dirais miller
était pour lui faire une liste de tous
les produits et et que tu as testé oula
ça paraît beaucoup de temps comment on
fait tout pour être au courant des
dernières nouveautés high-tech gens
soient groupe communiqué de presse je
lis la presse je vais sur plein de sites
oui qovu trois pros ou rémy 28 87 et le
monsieur gros je crois que tu as
récupéré le clavier mocky beau encore et
est ce que tu leur commande alors je les
tester encore et je les récupérer mais
je ne vais pas déballé depuis et entre
je trouvais assez cool assez prometteur
sous les dettes et très très bonne tu
cours c'est quoi comme smartphone vers
200 euros car je cherche un bon
smartphone je te conseille leurs
méthodes cette petite question pour un
budget de 300 euros remy notre cette
honte à vous faire partager les actions
chez shiomi pas du tout laisse parfois
des cas elles plutôt cool dans un petit
prix est ce que tu penses que sheholli
peut battre apple avec leur iphone je ne
pense pas que shiomi puisse battre apple
dans l'immédiat je pense qu'en volume
global de vente
il se peut qu'ils battent apple pas tout
de suite mais c'est possible parce qu'il
ya tellement de produits que forcément
forcément ça peut peser dans la balance
est ce qu'on aura une sortie du mx 4 je
pense que oui est ce que tu peux faire
gagner un samsung un concours par
exemple je ferai des concours un peu
plus tard ça ce qui va se structurer
aussi il ya tellement de choses en ce
moment que c'est un peu la course mais
plus tard dans les tuyaux tout cas rémi
note 7 ou mia 3 rémy dans cette je
souhaite changer de téléphone
actuellement j'ai un ou une + 3 t
pour lui qu'elle changeait google pixels
3 à one + 7 pro ou one plus c'est taylor
s'est pas tu as fait les mêmes produits
que tu met dans la balance un
utilisation jeu au pied photo j'ai mes
réseaux sociaux et téléphones se laisse
bien évidemment hellfest 2020 elle fait
2020 ça c'est sûr moi je dirais de +7
propre très clairement et pourquoi pas
où en plus cette table pro mais ça on en
reparle dans quelques jours à 70 ou à 80
de samsung
je dirais à 80 faut-il acheter une
voiture sans ses roues
c'est une super idée par contre faut
juste y aller ou en plus ça va coûter
cher tout dépend bien sûr du prix la
voiture pourrais tu faire un speed test
de smartphones sur ta chienne je suis
pas sûr que ça soit intéressant du
bonheur si ça vous intéresse en bas aux
commentaires que choisir entre le may 30
et le pétr en pro b trampo peux tu faire
une vidéo expliquant les différentes
technologies de charge rapide peut-être
une fois de plus si ça vous intéresse
dit le manga en commentaire qu'est ce
que tu me conseilles entre galaxies buzz
ou dis d'accord nomades galaxie boutique
mais avec le bon paramétrage te renvoie
à ma vidéo sur les galaxies buzz et tu
auras le bon paramètres pour que le son
soit vraiment cool est ce que tu me
conseilles les honorer 8x oui grand
écran bien smartphone coule entre la
gamme apple et la gamme galaxy laquelle
vous êtes vraiment fan pour
l'utilisation alors saluons les deux
sont cool
il ya un système qui est assez fermé du
côté d'apple et qui marche parfaitement
bien j'aime beaucoup aussi ce que fait
samsung c'est beaucoup plus ouvert bien
évidemment c'est vraiment une question
d'affinités aloès d'affinités à la
marque personnellement j'aime bien les
deux sens utile possible sur la chaîne
que tu nous parles de batterie externe
je sais pas si c'est vraiment très
intéressant comme sujet de manière
globale quels sont les points forts et
faibles du haut de gamme de la marque
huawei alors le point fort c'est 4
beaucoup de recherche et développement
via un hardware qui est énorme
du côté de chez huawei le point faible
c'est l' os je trouve que l'euro est
pour l'instant est pas encore vraiment
très très bon en tout cas le m8 m.brahim
on voulait le prononcer et pas officines
il ya beaucoup de travail à faire là
dessus ça apple pour table aujourd'hui
on fait ton macbook va mieux mais mon
macbook il va pas beaucoup mieux
bleu au milieu
les oranges sur le côté c'est vrai
catastrophe
as tu des smartphones de nubie à tester
prochainement malheureusement non quel
smartphone utilises-tu pour l'instant
c'est toujours loin de plus être pro
mais ça va bientôt changer
pourrais-tu tester d'autres marques de
smartphones qui ne sont pas en france a
il y en a déjà beaucoup à tester en ce
moment peut-être plus tard mais
peut-être que peut-on faire soit dans un
téléphone voire très très vieux il faut
leur cycle et je trouvais d'aller voir
des vendeurs des boutiques physiques
pour voir comment le recycler et ou lors
pourquoi pas du dur conditionné s'ils
reprennent en tout cas peut-être le
recycler c'est ce qu'il faut faire c'est
très important pour eux tu me donner un
site qui vend les samsung galaxy à 60,10
vraiment pas cher il ya plein de sida
s'est reposé sur sur amazon penses tu
que mort et va trouver une solution avec
google et autre chose c'est pas moi
ouais c'est la chine qui va trouver une
solution avec les us c'est forcément
forcément il y aura une solution
politiquement un autre et google et
huawei vont être impactés par cette
décision mais je pense que ça risque de
s'arranger samsung galaxy s 9 ou et 10 e
et 10 e
j'ai un poco phone et je souhaite
acheter un mine afte et dans un ou deux
ans je jouais n'importe où même qui
n'ont le 1900 dans un ou deux ans 1990
un ou deux ans peut-être dans un an dans
deux ans dont il sera complètement
déjoué en tout cas il sera bien passé
rémy notsè tour il mit trois pros rémy
noter qu'en est il selon toi des
performances du prochain smartphone de
huawei et de son os je n'ai pas testé
donc je peux pas en parler quel est le
meilleur smartphone de petite taille
mais les iphones en 5,8 pouces marche
bien samsung y reste trois ou fossile
cinquième génération sachant que j'ai un
essuie tu peux mettre les deux mois je
te conseille quand même là fossiles
cinquième génération pour les paramètres
au niveau de la batterie ça c'est cool
qu'elle phone entre le au port hainaut
et le xiaomi 1009e d'urémie 9 calais le
smartphone entre galaxy note 10 plus et
l'iphone on se promet max une fois de
plus c'est la question du style et les
deux sont bons photo le onze pros match
entre pierre de tester il est en tout
cas très très intéressant samsung galaxy
à 5 entrées minaude 7 ou aux nordistes
galles excepté pas mal tu penses tu que
le nouveau xiaomi annoncé le mix alpha
surpassera huawei alors est-ce qu'il
surpassera ou pas je sais pas je n'ai
pas pris en en tout cas l'air vraiment
intéressant vas tu faire une
présentation du lg g8 ou lg g8 est ce
pas forcément parce que lg en france en
tout cas travail plus trop le smartphone
ça a été difficile pour eux pour
l'instant il laisse un peu de côté donc
bon je pense pas trop qu'on en parle ça
lui va tuer les corps et on studio et
quand
suis en train de le faire j'ai commandé
des affiches qui pour l'instant sont pas
arrivés j'ai plein d'idées il me faut un
petit peu de temps et à chaque fois que
j'y suis je cours donc le temps mais pas
vraiment que je le fasse
d'ailleurs si vous avez des idées pour y
aller aussi haut en bas en commentaire à
l'avenir sur la chaîne sera-t-il
possible que tu parles d'écouté au
format usb si j'ai pas compris félix la
question salut j'ai un iphone 7
j'aimerais changer pour un one + 7 t est
ce que ça vaut le coup oui oui carrément
clairement c'est autre chose
salut pourtant c'est quoi le meilleur
smartphone entre le galaxy à 40 le matin
light et le paie 30 live tu me poses une
superbe question je dirais le contact
est ce que tu va tester le xiaomi renmin
occuperont oui on me le demande beaucoup
je pense que je testerai il faut que je
voie les chiots vite les dispos est-ce
qu'il est là quoi comment je vous tiens
au courant
prochainement je me demande depuis que
tu as des ménages et elle est où la moto
à les revenus la moto est revenu j'ai eu
un accident de moto début juillet une
voiture qui m'a renversé qui accouchent
et tout ça alors rien n'est grave de mon
côté par contre la moto ça prive des
mois le temps que duke et y envoient les
pièces voilà fabre est donc là elle est
de retour tout va bien mais j'aimerais
acheter un nouveau téléphone est ce que
tu me conseilles le huawei mehdaoui de
sur son problème
j'ai un iphone 10 s max je voulais
savoir si ça vaut la peine d'acheter un
onze pros max non émis restent très
actuelle le smartphone que tu as changé
pour changer ça c'est rien ça va te
coûter cher je pense pas qu'ils aient un
gap énorme
garde ton smartphone doit-on s'inquiéter
du das lorsqu'on achète un smartphone
c'est important c'est très important le
das c'est le débit spécifique
d'absorption c'est ça correspond aux
ombres que votre corps va absorber
lorsque vous avez téléphoné les
smartphones qui sont en france respecte
la loi donc normalement vous n'avez pas
d'inquiétude à vous faire mais plus
d'assez bas et mieux c'est salut
aurélien je trouve que tu as un bon
rythme de vidéos même à vanter sans
cadre du coup je me dis soit est hyper
efficace soit a pas de vie privée soit
t'es pas tout seul dans son armure
un peu des trois gibert qu'est ce que tu
me conseilles entre une apple watch et
la fossiles les deux sont bien moi ce
que j'aime c'est que la fossiles de
cinquième génération c ela fait de
pouvoir paramétrer ce que vous allez
utiliser comme application ce qui va
être actif pour vraiment optimisé la
batterie ça qu'on voit c'est vraiment
cool qu'est ce que tu penses de
minecraft
hertz absolument rien fait parce que je
n'utilise pas est-ce que tu faire un
jour une vidéo sur le web + 7 t pro est
bonne plus être des pros mclaren edition
on en parlera tout ça très très
prochainement à quand la vidéo test du
rock funds dans quelques jours galaxie
web s'activent au galaxy s active 2
watts active 2 quand on voit
l'écosystème d'apple penses-tu qu'un
équivalent en exil
c'est particulier apple ça marche très
très bien il y a plein de solutions à
droite à gauche notamment chez huawei
comment ça pas développer ça mais le kpl
reste quand même un cas d'école et c'est
un petit peu particulier pour lui faire
une compagne en surtout sa comparaison
je ne suis pas sûr j'ai pas trop les
comparaisons
ah bon tu pourrais parler du mix alpha
je vais faire mon maximum pour pouvoir
en parler je suis au mit d'ailleurs si
vous regardez cette vidéo je suis pour
la brave tu me conseilles quoi entre eux
un chiot mimi 9 091 honor view vingt
neuf ou une occase très récente au one +
6 t d'occasion mois que le conseil le
mil neuf des pros je t'aime beaucoup
mettons générique était chez d'ailleurs
dit moi si vous aimez génériques ne vous
génériques ou pas ce que vous en pensez
j'ai plein d'avis différents
il y en a qui aiment y en a qui n'aiment
pas dites moi vous ce que vous en pensez
que vous aimez oui non comment marquer
le mans battu tester le huawei y neuf
prime 2009 je ne pense pas parce qu'on
est sur un smartphone d'entrée de gamme
et que huawei communique à ses coups
dessus je suis même pas sûr qu'il en est
en test nouvel ipad 2019 au épanouie
2019 nouvel ipad 2 mai 19 c'est possible
d'avoir une estimation du prix du one
piece septs essais sous embargo
j'ai le prix et les dates de sortie mais
pour l'instant je ne peux pas vous en
parler on en parle la semaine prochaine
est-ce que lui poko phone est fort reste
un bon smartphone fin 2019 ou le webp 20
les deux sont bien sûr l'actualité
voilà on a fait un tour complet de cette
faq plein de questions très peu de temps
20 minutes quand même il ya un peu de
montage a fermé il ya pas mal de choses
à dire j'attends toutes vos questions
pour la prochaine fois qu on pouvait
marquer en bas en commentaire vous me
posez toutes vos questions tout ce que
vous voulez savoir
excusez-moi sénat quelques-unes que j'ai
un peu zappé j'ai dû faire un choix il
avait beaucoup beaucoup plus de 84 ans a
fait beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
retraités en tout cas merci à vous puis
là je vais filet il ya une petite
rencontre entre la presse microsoft ce
soit qui demain souriez bien au rendez
vous parce qu'on va parler une microsoft
des nouveautés on va aller faire un tour
dans new york il va y avoir des trucs
franchement hypra coule sur ce je vous
embrasse et je vous dis à demain ciao